and speaking of dinner turning now to a
topic that will interest anyone with a
passion for food many of the recipes in
afghan cuisine have been passed down
generation to generation family to
family mother to daughter now one couple
with roots in afghanistan is updating
that tradition in their successful
washington area restaurants the mass
roar family decided to put the women
front and center for our series the dish
jan crawford shows us their powerful
recipe for change
when sophia mesrier is making her famous
leaking scallion dumplings she smiles
i just love it because it reminds me of
my childhood it's my all-time favorite
dish
a childhood that began in afghanistan
before her family fled to the united
states after the soviet invasion when
the country was a cosmopolitan
celebration of cultures
my mother when she would make this dish
my favorite part was to do this oh
really yes
sit around the dining room table and we
would stuff the
wrappers
the delicate leek and scallion dumplings
are just one of the classic dishes
featured in sofia and husband omar's
washington d.c area afghan restaurants
which they started as a way to share
their country's sophisticated cuisine
every african restaurant you would go to
is just kebab kebab kebab
which is not the tradition it's not
traditional there's so much more there's
so much more to afghan food food
influenced by the many cultures that
formed afghanistan food that's going to
be coming from central asia you know
from china
india
the persians
so it's a mixture of of everything this
food is like afghanistan a combination
of cultures
and different ethnicities and
backgrounds all coming together in like
a beautiful harmony which country that
you can go to or which
nation you could go today you could get
a rice dish that's gonna have raisins in
there that's gonna have carrots in there
that's gonna have almonds walnuts
meat pistachios
today afghanistan is anything but
harmonious
and seeing it return to taliban control
led the musr to make a statement last
fall that went well beyond food
omar decided to step back from the
operations and put the women his wife's
sister and his two oldest daughters in
charge i said listen the only way to do
a change or to make a statement is you
have to
from inside to do something not through
words not through anything but through
action
what was the statement that you were
trying to make them women can do
anything oldest daughter talia is the
new manager of bistro arakasiya running
all the restaurants day-to-day
operations amman is manager in training
at the mclean location sometimes people
ask me for the manager and i'm like well
i am the manager
what does it mean to you to kind of be a
part of this statement that you're
making oh it makes me feel good that
they think that
i can manage a restaurant and run a
restaurant i want to be ceo of the
restaurants and just learn how to do
everything
the critically acclaimed restaurants the
women now in charge continue to expand
locations they attribute their success
to the customers and the recipes that
span generations from one mother to the
next i mean i learned this from my
mother so
that's how she made it that's how i made
it and
that's how i'm teaching
others to make it
and now passing again to the next what
is your dream for your
your daughters
as they grow up
to know who they are that's all i just
want them to to to know that they could
do anything they want to do they can run
a business they can be a ceo better
better what's your dream for their
futures for them to you know be
confident believe in themselves
um
be kind human beings
you know it's just also it's not just
about them it's about everyone and for
all those other girls needing to hear
you can do it jan crawford cbs mornings
mclean virginia
i love that when he was asked you know
what do you want your daughters to know
that they can do anything run a business
he said better better better they can do
anything they want in this world which
is incredible and the food looks really
good
really good always good when you want to
lick the screen
always nicely done jan